tenemos que ganar la casa blanca y
estamos en camino a lograrlo pero
y hablando con nuestros amigos de
virginia más de 12 millones de votos no
han sido contados en virginia entonces
espera vamos a ver qué trae eso y qué
significa para la carrera presidencial
pero estoy aquí solamente para
saludar a los demócratas y a nuestros
candidatos no solamente en términos de
cifras no se trata sólo de cantidad se
trata de la calidad del liderazgo que
han ofrecido para el país
todos estamos ahí en el congreso para la
gente y para tener un plan estratégico
para tener éxito para mantener nuestro
control y mantener el control de la
cámara no podríamos estar mejor servidos
entonces a todos a todos esos pilares
para ganar la elección fue una
movilización desde las bases
ya sea que se trate de el mensaje de una
manera muy exitosa
o de conseguir el dinero se han roto los
récords
ya mantuvo el respeto de los miembros de
la cámara y la confianza de los
candidatos entonces con eso quiero
reconocer de nuevo
pero si muchas gracias por sus palabras
amables y obviamente su liderazgo en
este caucus ha sido increíble estoy aquí
desde illinois que es mi amigo estado
natal
y es como el centro de eeuu aquí la
gente se toman eso muy en serio y
trabajan duro se cuidan unos a otros es
alrededor de lugares como este donde si
tu vecino se enferma tú la llevas una
comida o ofreces cuidar a sus hijos en
2018 los demócratas ganaron de nuevo la
cámara llegando a personas en lugares
como modi escuchándolos y esto es lo que
la gente en aquellos lugares del centro
de eeuu nos dijeron lo que llevamos a la
elección del 2020 y es que quieren un
gobierno que funcione para ellos quieren
más progreso menos partidismo quieren el
fin de la corrupción y de los intereses
especiales y sobre todo quieren salud y
punto
quieren saber que sus familias están
cubiertas y saber en sus corazones lo
que los demócratas han seguido señalando
que cada vez que los republicanos han
tenido la oportunidad de acabar con las
protecciones de salud para los
trabajadores los republicanos lo han
hecho eso es un hecho
y sin importar que seas una madre con
cáncer un padre que sobrevivió un ataque
al corazón un joven que tenía asma los
republicanos no van a descansar hasta
que le quiten a la gente las
protecciones que aún tienen para tener
un seguro de salud nunca hemos dejado de
hablar de salud y ahora
que están cerrando los centros de
votación podemos ver lo que de nuevo el
port estadounidense ha determinado que
sigamos protegiendo esto particularmente
en medio de una pandemia quieren que el
partido de la salud los represente el
partido democracia ese es su muro en
contra de la irresponsabilidad de los
republicanos en washington y es una gran
responsabilidad pero el pueblo ha puesto
al partido correcto en la cámara con los
costos de los medicamentos de
prescripción muy altos ahora hemos
aprobado una ley y con la
corrupción tan grande hemos aprobado la
mayor legislación anti corrupción en una
generación
racing
para proteger los empleos llevamos a
cabo el moving forward act nunca hemos
dejado de trabajar para el pueblo y con
una pandemia que se ha cobrado casi un
cuarto de millón de vidas
estamos ante este reto que enfrentamos
mañana y durante los próximos años eso
es lo que la gente espera aquí a
nosotros y es lo que merecen quieren que
sigamos los mismos valores que enseñan
al uso de sus hijos respeto trabajo duro
y el aprecio de aquellos que no se ven
como tuvo como tu familia estos son los
valores que representan
al partido y cuando los recordamos
recordamos a la gente de lugares como
medellín en ganamos y todo el país gana
entonces sentamos agradecidos por esta
oportunidad pero también seamos humildes
hay millones de votos que aún tiene que
ser contados nuestro camino para el eeuu
que todos queremos y en lo que creemos
está justo en frente de nosotros señora
pero así muchas gracias por su liderazgo
y nunca vamos a perder de vista cómo
utilizar su poder como presidenta a la
cámara para las familias para los niños
y para un mejor futuro realmente es un
honor increíble poder servir a su lado
muchas gracias y buenas noches gracias
es un honor también servir con usted y
todos nos sentimos honrados de servir
con
este coco es tan dinámico el más diverso
en la historia de cualquier país
incluyendo el nuestro entonces ahora con
esta victoria vamos a proceder a
preparar para la transición
hablaremos de lo que hemos hablado desde
el principio
para las personas que quieren menos
costos a nivel de salud de medicamentos
proteger las condiciones preexistentes
así como a otros de los ataques que los
republicanos continúan haciendo en
tiempos presentes en las cortes sobre
todo en la corte suprema de eeuu para el
pueblo vamos a aumentar los pagos
construyendo infraestructuras de eeuu de
una manera verde y resistente creando
trabajos y oportunidades para la equidad
sobre todo para las empresas que
participan en estos procesos con el
desarrollo de la fuerza laboral con
educación para